just come back for my workout while
listening to version
um all I want to say is you know don't
worry about your lofty goals and what
you hope to achieve and you know uh
Illusions about how fluently you're
going to speak the language or how much
money you're going to make worry about
what you do every minute that's
available to you get active
you can work out wherever you are either
I go down to the gym or I get on my uh
you know off my iPad I can download some
kettlebell routines
we never have a chance I listen to my
language or I sit there and I work my
way through either sentence mode or you
know full lesson mode take advantage of
every minute get some good habits and
eventually your long-term goals you will
get there if you have you know good
habits where you're really taking
advantage of all your opportunities to
stay healthy to learn languages and to
be a good person anyway that's all I'd
say I'll talk to you again soon and I
should do these more often